- Hi everyone, this is Jeremy
Schifeling with Khan Academy.
I wanna thank you for
joining us this afternoon
or this evening, depending on
where you're calling in from.
And you're in for a very special treat.
So as you probably know, we've
been doing webinars everyday,
twice a day, three times a
day here at Khan Academy,
but I have to confess,
I have never seen a session
like the one Tim lead
a couple weeks ago where
he basically blew minds
all across the country
by talking about the results
he got with mastery learning
in his classroom.
So much so that Tim has gone on
to chat with Sal Khan directly,
and will actually be on Sal
Khan's live stream next week
if you've been tuning into that.
But if you want a sneak preview
into what he and Sal are gonna talk about,
you've come to the right place.
In fact, this is way more
than a sneak preview.
Thanks to the generosity of Tim,
we're gonna get a deep dive
into everything he does
in his classroom, the
actual use of Khan Academy,
his grade book, and all that good detail
so you can apply the same
in your own classroom
either tomorrow or even next fall
if you're already thinking about that.
So that being said,
Tim has asked to run a couple
of polls just to get started.
We'd love to get a sense of the
folks in the room right now.
So did you see Tim's original
webinar a couple weeks ago
where he sort of laid out his experience
of mastery of learning
and the results he was getting?
And it looks like that about 2/3
of the votes coming in, Tim,
there's actually a huge
chunk of new fans here,
more than 3/4 actually.
So definitely a lot of folks who could use
a little bit of a refresher.
And then just to help Tim out as well,
tell us what grade level you teach?
That'll sort of help us tailor.
Obviously, Tim is coming at this
from a sixth grade perspective,
but he'll make sure to
speak to the realities
of other grade levels as well.
Okay, thanks every for
participating so quickly.
That's awesome.
Go ahead and share those results.
And so Tim, lots of fellow
elementary school folks.
But definitely a nice mix of folks
all the way up to college in fact.
So lots of hunger for the
kinds of things you're sharing.
That being said, Tim,
I'm gonna basically turn it over to you
because you've, again, been so generous
with your time and expertise
to put together a whole
nother slide deck for us.
Which also, by the way,
is attached in the handout section
and will be emailed to you
along with a recording.
Tim is gonna spend about 30 minutes
walking through all of this.
And then we're gonna
take your questions live
from the audience.
So Tim, thank you again.
Take it away.
- Okay, well, since there was a good chunk
of the live audience who have
not seen the original webinar,
let me first highly
recommend that you go back
and watch that.
But I will go a little bit
slower than anticipated
on the initial review materials
so that you're caught up to speed.
So let's see, do I have my
screen showing correctly?
Jeremy?
- Coming through loud
and clear.
- The slides are correct?
Okay, good.
Okay so Mastery Learning with Khan Academy
and how to achieve massive results.
So just off the bat, I want you to know
that as a sixth grade
teacher in a low income area
in the High Desert area of California,
halfway between LA and Vegas,
my kids are like most kids in America.
They're not coming from affluent homes.
10% of them come to me at grade level,
90% below grade level.
Half of them far below.
And nearly all of my students are reading
two or more years below grade level
when they come to me.
And so comparing my class,
this is my class down here.
I'm comparing my class with
the state of California
and the county I teach in
and the district I teach in.
You can see where my students are relative
to all those, this is a passing grade
in fifth grade and in sixth grade.
Normalizing the scores,
you can compare apples
to apples of growth.
And my students were about a were a good
about 20 points below the
average California student
which is still really far below.
And we'll talk about more of this later,
but I want you to see my
kids are not at grade level.
So much like most of
your students as well.
And so in September 2016, I
watched a TED Talk from Sal.
And you really need to
go watch this TED Talk.
And right at about the, I
think it's the four-minute,
30-second mark, somewhere in there,
Sal gives a powerful analogy of education
under the old school model
is kind of like, imagine
building a building, like a
two or three-story building,
or even taller.
And giving instead of a fixed expectation
of the building being safe and solid
and firmly on a great foundation,
instead, basing your
building on a timeline,
saying, for example, all
right, you have two weeks
to build a foundation.
Do what you can.
And two weeks later, the
building inspector comes.
And he says, "Well, you got
some wet cement over here.
"You don't have some
foundational posts over there.
"That's pretty good.
"You got an 80%.
"Build the next level."
Well, everybody knows in their right mind,
if you keep up with that analogy
from first floor to second
floor to third floor,
eventually, the building's the crumble.
And that's exactly like the way
we run education in America.
We say, "Okay, you've got nine months,
"so do what you can."
And we don't have time to go back
and fix the foundation of the years before
these kids come to us.
We just have to teach to the
current grade level standards,
and they get what they
get and you pass 'em on.
And you give 'em a good
grade if they try hard.
But really do they pass the state test?
Probably not.
So the big takeaway from Sal's talks
is this idea of mastery
learning, if you see
that at the bottom there.
Mastery learning is a different mindset.
It's developing each skill to fluency
and longterm retention
where the fixed variable
is mastery rather than the time allotted.
You say, "Okay, I don't care
how long it takes you to learn
"let's say, solving
single variable equations,
"but you're gonna master this
"before the state test.
"You might take longer than most kids.
"You might learn it
after the quiz we take,
"but you're gonna learn this
"and that's the expectation."
Versus, "You gotta a week,
"and if you don't learn it, too bad.
"We're moving on.
"Your grade's stuck for that
assignment, that skill."
Mastery learning is a different mindset.
We'll talk more about that later.
So I had decided after watching
that video from Sal
that I was totally done
with building on these
dangerous foundations
of unstable mathematical concepts.
These kids just didn't grasp
what the meaning of numbers were,
place value, fractions,
what equations are, and
why we're subtracting
or adding to both sides at the same time.
They just think that math
is about memorizing algorithms,
as opposed to truly understanding
what's going on.
So I decided that from now on,
I'm gonna teach students
with a solid foundation.
And Khan Academy was gonna
help me make that happen.
So in fall of 2016, I
chose three years ago,
now four school years ago pretty much
to take my kids back to kindergarten.
We're gonna go back to kindergarten
with the help of Khan Academy
and master all these skills
so that we have a solid
foundation to build on.
So beautifully, Khan Academy has all
these different grade level courses.
So I assigned K through five in addition
to my sixth grade standards
that my sixth graders
were supposed to learn.
And I expected them to master everything.
And let's see what happened.
So after three school years of doing this,
each of the past three school years,
my sixth graders have grown.
Their results have looked like this.
You see that little dot on the left.
Vandenberg 18/19, 60 points below.
If you look at California,
I pick the best growth
for California students, the
largest educational market
in the nation.
The best growth of the last
three years, cohort growth,
they grew that year, 2017-18 school year,
they grew 1.2 points
towards a passing score.
Now even just a flat
year of growth is good.
That means you gave
'em a year harder test,
and they stayed at the same level.
So you kept 'em where they were
by teaching them a whole
year's worth of material.
They stayed about where they were.
So even just flat growth is good.
Well, here's what happened with my kids
after using this mastery learning model,
going back and filling in the gaps.
We went from 60 points below,
to 34 points above.
All totaled, it's about
94, 95 points of growth,
on average, for every student in my class.
Every kid went up.
The one kid who went up the most,
he went up 193 points.
He was an IEP special ed kid.
One of the most, sweet boy,
but one of the most hyperactive, ADHD boys
I'd ever had in 25 years of teaching.
And he grew immensely
thanks to Khan Academy,
and so did the whole rest of the class.
So these are the kids.
And their lives were changed forever.
This is real.
You know, if those kids
look like your kids,
you know, just your normal, average
American student, well there you go.
That's them, just like your class.
If they can do it, so can your kids too.
So how do you make this happen?
First, I highly recommend,
now this is new material from here on out.
For those of you who have
watched the former webinar.
We're gonna deep dive into my brief points
on the first webinar.
First, familiarize yourself
with what mastery learning
actually is, okay?
Mastery learning, watch these two videos
and the one linked up above
in the slide deck up above.
Those three videos from Sal Khan himself
where he explains what
mastery learning is.
Really wrap your mind around that.
A lot of questions I received
in the last three weeks,
about half of them have
come to me from teachers,
I can tell, they really
haven't quite grasped
what mastery learning is.
They still wanna teach
under the old model.
And bless them for wanting to reach out
and try some new tricks that might work.
But if you really want huge growth,
you really gotta accept and deep dive
into this mastery learning model.
If you wanna see what this
looks like in a classroom,
in fact, in my classroom,
that's the video linked there.
And then you can watch my earlier webinar
right there on that link.
So you can see all that from
the first go round we had.
So moving on.
So here's some best practices
for mastery learning.
First, some disclaimers.
Every classroom and school
and district situation is different.
You need to adjust and make this work
for your students.
There's no one-size fits all.
You need to use your
professional judgment.
You still need to follow
whatever rules and expectations
from your department,
your grade level team,
your administrators, your district.
At the same time, it's certainly helped
when I went to my principal
and I asked permission to try
something vastly different.
And he gave me permission
to try just one year.
If my state test results went up,
then he let me keep doing.
And that's exactly what happened.
Number two disclaimer, this
is a major paradigm shift
from the traditional
time-driven learning model
to the mastery-driven learning model.
You need to think differently.
You need to think differently from,
"Okay, I'm gonna teach it,
"and then we're gonna do
some practice homework,
"and then I'm gonna give a quiz.
"And whatever grade they got, that's it.
"We're moving on."
This is a different mindset
where kids can still go back in
and continue to master skills
while still keeping up with
the class on the new stuff.
And grades are never solid
until report cards come out.
That's when grades are locked in.
Number three disclaimer, for
many, if not most students,
in America and in the world, really,
this is a matter of
educational life and death.
Are you willing to treat it as such?
Or are you just gonna stick
with the epically failed,
time-driven status quo?
You've gotta decide, look, you might
be the last chance your
students ever have.
You might be the only teacher
in their whole K-12 educational life
who will say, "You know what,
"enough is enough, I'm
gonna make sure my kids
"get the foundation they need."
Maybe for high school teachers,
you're gonna make them do early math,
arithmetic, and pre-algebra.
Elementary teachers, early
math and arithmetic only,
in addition to your current
grade level material.
But you gotta decide, hey,
am I gonna change their life,
or are they just gonna continue to pretend
they're passing classes
'cause they try hard,
but they never really master it.
They fail the state test every year.
Their learning is fake.
We're lying to parents about their grades.
An A is not really an A.
An A just means they're nice, well-behaved
and work hard on homework and classwork.
And I give 'em an A,
and I move 'em on even though
they just failed the state test.
Or are you gonna just
say, "The buck stops here.
"I'm gonna make a difference.
"We're gonna do something different
"and change these kid's lives."
So I hope you join me in that adventure,
but that's up to you.
Make sure you get permission
from administrators
or your department team
or whatever you need so
that you're not in trouble
for doing what I believe is morally
and ethically right for all kids.
All right, so here's some tips.
Getting more in detail, these main points,
one through the first nine of these
are from the original webinar,
but the details underneath
are new for people to see.
So we'll look at these in
detail, slowly, one at a time.
So here we go.
Pardon me.
So number one, be honest and
face the state test facts.
Where are your students actually at?
Look at their state test scores
from the year before or whatever
district diagnostic test
or anything that'll show the
real truth of how they compare
to state expectations and
national norms and so on.
Where are they really at?
If their previous year teacher
said they got an A or a B,
that might mean they're a good student,
but that doesn't mean
they mastered the skills
from the previous year.
How many times have you told yourself,
"What were they teaching them
"the year before?"
And I guarantee you that that teacher
the year before was
thinking the same thing
in August, September, at
the start of the year too.
And so on and so on, all the
way down in kindergarten.
What were they teaching them in preschool?
And the preschool's saying,
"What were they teaching
"them at home?"
So that's not your business.
What is your business is
where are they at right now?
So I highly recommend that
you focus on your students'
actual cohort growth history.
Where are they growing?
And how did your students
who just graduated
the year before, how did they grow before?
I gotta tell you, I
also taught high school
and junior high,
not just sixth grade, even though the bulk
of my 25 years was sixth grade.
And even Jeremy doesn't know this.
For six years, I was adjunct professor
at the University of
Redlands in California,
Teacher Credential program,
and I worked with student teachers
as their once a week symposium teacher,
as they check in during
the hardest semester.
They're teaching life.
It's called student teaching.
We've all been through that.
So I've seen it all.
We all know about high school teachers,
junior high teachers, elementary teachers
who might be very proud of
their state test scores.
You know, maybe their kids,
their average scores in their
class were at grade level.
But if you look at their growth,
they might have actually gone down.
Maybe they came to them at an advanced,
above grade level score,
but by the time they graduated them,
their scores actually went down.
They might still be at grade level,
but they didn't actually keep
them level or bring them up.
Which to me is what a
successful teacher is.
So look at that growth history,
and be honest with yourself about that.
And so when I saw that, I said,
"I need to do something different
"'cause it's not working."
So focus on growth, not the final scores.
And then finally, if possible,
discuss the growth data with your team,
your department, administration,
and most importantly,
parents and students, show,
I highly recommend this.
This is what I do at Back to School Night
and parent-teacher conferences.
Show the whole class results,
and then provide individual
student results individually.
I'm not gonna show any individual scores,
but I have loaded up what I showed
at the start of this school year.
Jeremy, are you able to see this?
- Yep, coming through.
- Okay, so this is what
I showed at the start
of this school year.
This is my previous school year's kids,
the same kids you just saw in that chart
where they grew a lot.
This is basically almost
the same scores every year.
They come to me the previous year.
This is what they look
like the previous year.
About three kids at grade level.
That's this in the green here.
Nobody in advanced, above grade level.
I sure would like to be
one of those teachers
that gets a population up here,
and a bunch of kids down
here above at grade level.
This is a typical report from my district
on how kids did on state
test the year before.
And then this is where
most of my kids are.
Now, they call this a nice word.
They call this, "Standards Nearly Met".
But if green, level three
means at grade level,
what do you call yellow, level two?
That means not at grade level.
To me, that means they
failed the previous year.
In my case, they failed fifth grade.
And then there's the kids,
the biggest chunk of my kids
far below grade level, far below.
And I can't tell you
how many of these kids
got As and Bs from their
teachers in fifth grade
'cause they worked hard, they were nice,
they did their best,
then they got an A or a B.
And their parents come to me and say,
"My child never got less than an A,
"or never got less than a B
on their report cards in math.
"So what are you gonna do
with my kid this year?"
Well I show them the reality.
You need to show your parents the reality.
This is reality.
Do you want me to give your child an A
when they failed at grade level,
or do you want me to be honest with you
and do something differently
to make a difference?
Besides, parents, this is what happened
and this is what I do.
I show them all these.
These are failing scores in each domain.
Concepts, procedures, problem
solving, modeling data,
communicating, reasoning.
Orange is failing, like far below.
The gray could be at, could be below.
It's like near grade level.
And the light blue is like advanced.
Not so good.
This is reality.
You need to show your
parents, your administrators,
your team reality.
And have a reality check with them.
But then, show them what
happens with the growth.
If you do this for one
year, show them the growth.
So I show them before
and then here comes the after.
Ready for this?
Boom.
Those are the exact same kids leveled up
those 90 or so points.
Yeah, there is one kid
still down here in the red,
but I'll tell you,
this kid actually went up like 100 points.
And then all those kids
that were in the red
moved up to yellow.
And then all those kids in
the yellow moved up to green.
And all these advanced kids moved up.
This is real.
And look at all these domain scores.
Look at all these advanced,
and all this orange
like almost went away.
This is real growth.
And when I had success
the very first year,
this is what I do.
I show the next year's parents.
Here's the before, and
your kids, by the way,
are just like this.
And if you want the after,
I can make this happen
if you want it.
So show that data.
And until then, until you have some data
to show that to administrators,
talk to them about
where they're really at,
and why are we beating a dead horse
and being like that fly,
hitting their head against the window,
thinking they'll eventually get through?
You gotta do something different.
The definition of insanity is
continuing to do what fails
over and over, people say,
expecting it to change.
So quit the insanity and
do something different.
So be honest with the state test results.
So back to our presentation.
I think it's this over here.
Okay?
So show them all that.
Next.
Number two, acknowledge
that math is cumulative.
Prerequisite skills are exactly that,
pre-required, not pre-suggested.
You can't teach kids how
to multiply, divide, add,
and subtract fractions and mixed numbers
unless they even understand
what a fraction is.
And they can't even figure that out
until they understand
the meaning of numbers and
number sense and place value
and of all that.
So they need to master those skills.
Otherwise, they will continue
for the rest of their lives
until they choose to quit school
or think that they're dumb
when they're not.
They're just gonna think
the school that math
is all about algorithms,
memorizing algorithms,
and having no clue what it all means.
So get away from memorizing algorithms.
Focus on meaning and understanding
what's really going on
by going back, even back to kindergarten,
and having them master
those prerequisite skills
and number sense concepts.
Number three, in order to
do that, use Khan Academy
to remediate and fill in foundational gaps
by assigning remedial
course mastery expectations.
I assigned early math,
or you can individually
assign K, one, two, three,
whatever grade levels are below you.
Also, the arithmetic course
covers, I would say kindergarten
through seventh grade arithmetic
dealing with positive,
negative, integers, add,
subtract, multiply, divide
and order of operations.
That a little bit gets
into seventh grade as well.
So that's a good review for junior high
and high school teachers.
And then the pre algebra
course is excellent review
for secondary teachers
teaching above pre algebra.
So that's an excellent review.
Next, teach.
You're still teaching.
You don't just say, "All
right, everybody go on Khan
"and figure it out yourself."
You still teach.
The grade level common
core standards to mastery.
Don't just cover the
standards, master them.
Expect mastery.
Number five, believe that
every child can learn.
It's called growth mindset.
So what you should do is you should assign
like the first week of school.
And I know it's kind of late now,
but you can still assign
this to your kids now
change their lives now.
Don't wait till the fall.
Assign this remotely as we're
all doing remote learning.
The growth mindset
lessons on Khan Academy.
Tell your kids get on there.
Tell 'em it's extra credit.
Tell 'em it'll change their lives,
it's totally worth it if
you haven't done it already.
So if you go to Khan Academy.
I'm gonna pull up that tab.
Okay, up here in the Courses tab.
Over here in College Careers and more
is this Growth Mindset Course.
So assign that to your kids, it's amazing.
The videos are amazing.
Do them together as a class.
Talk about them.
Do the activities, it's fantastic.
So definitely be doing that.
Okay.
And then back to the presentation.
Okay, growth mindset, also
part of growth mindset,
really emphasize and teach
the value of error analysis.
Learn from mistakes.
Mistakes are good.
The quickest, the fastest
growth that kids make
is when they stop and learn from mistakes.
Okay, what did I do wrong?
And that's where the
growing is the most powerful
and sticks with them the longest.
And the growth mindset videos
and lessons talk about that,
so make sure you do that.
Number six, teach,
support, teach, support.
And you're really teaching,
but then you support them.
You let the use Khan Academy
which gives instant feedback
after every question.
Did they understand it or not?
And let go and allow them
to have self-agency and initiative.
Let them own it.
So let me go back in Khan Academy.
Up here.
Okay, so over here on Progress,
if you go to your Progress tab,
I have assigned the sixth grade
and several other courses.
And this is my current class.
I've changed their names
to just two letters,
first and last name of each
so you don't know who's who.
A little privacy there for them.
But this is my class progress.
And these low performers down here,
these are special ed kids.
And they're actually mastering
their lower grade materials
for the first time in their life.
So I'm still proud of them.
They're still gonna have
huge growth on the state test
from where they were last year.
Even this kid here who's at
38% mastery for sixth grade,
on our practice state test practices,
he is crushing the practice state test
with at above grade level scores
on half of the practice tests
and at grade level scores
for the other half.
He's doing great, and so
are all the other kids,
doing the best that they've
ever done in their whole lives.
The Khan Academy research
which I leaned on
before I ever began this,
says that if kids master 40%
or more of their current
grade level standards,
they will outperform their
non Khan Academy peers
that don't use Khan Academy,
by about 50% on their state test.
And kids who master
60% from here and above
will outperform by 80%.
I'm pretty sure maybe, Jeremy, afterwards
can link the Khan Academy page that shows
that bar graph growth compared
to non-Khan using kids.
So I just want you to know.
And you might think,
"Well, we're almost done
with the school year.
"Why aren't more of your
kids, Tim, further along?"
I trust this.
This is real learning.
Not I covered it and I failed the test.
Those kids actually mastered this.
And these kids, all these kids at 60%,
approximately 60% or
higher, I anticipate them
achieving advanced, above grade level.
That level one on that chart,
or at grade level, but definitely
at grade level or above.
So they're gonna do great.
But then I used these charts.
So going back into teach,
support, teach, support.
What I do is I go into the unit,
the grade level unit that we're teaching,
I still teach.
So let's say here's the unit
we actually haven't even covered yet.
Check this out.
We have not even taught
this unit at all yet.
But because my students have,
I have allowed them to have
initiative and self-agency,
and the ability to move forward.
Without me even teaching the unit,
a third of my class is
already halfway done
with the whole unit.
And then another third is
a quarter done or more.
And then these are the kids
that are low and struggling
and they're not to this yet.
But when I get around to
teaching this unit next,
if we do come back from the
whole remote learning thing
that we're all going through right now.
When I do teach this unit,
I've already got 2/3 of my
class seeded with preknowledge
about what is going on.
So let's say, and here's
their growth on each skill.
So what I do is I'll go to the skill.
Let's say I wanna teach
how to calculate the mean.
So here, 17 kids still
haven't gotten to proficient
or familiar with that.
So calculate the mean.
I will teach this skill and
probably the next skill,
the median, and probably this and this.
I'll probably teach three
or four skills at once,
three or four skills together
over a good hour.
And then I'll let them loose.
Like, okay now, now go do it.
I bet you can do it just
like we did together
as a class.
I'll use my own computer
as like a student,
and we do some problems
together as a class.
And then I literally put
this up on the big screen.
And they would actually see their names,
but I'm not letting you see their names.
And I'll say, "Okay,
you wanna go to recess?
"You need to at least get to familiar,
"to this level, before recess.
"And you got 30 minutes before recess.
"I bet you can get to familiar
"especially since I'm here to help you.
"You neighbors are here to help you.
"The Khan videos and the Khan hints
"are all here to help you."
And as long as kids work
hard and do their best
and reach out for help
and persist and show grit
and show growth mindset,
I let 'em all go to recess.
And the ones that are you know,
there's always kids
that choose not to work.
And I hold 'em in.
Now you as a high school
teacher, junior high teacher,
you got different privileges or powers
that you can have over them.
But that's what I do.
Or I might say okay, for homework,
by tomorrow, you need to all
be over here at proficient,
or you know, let's see,
what do we call this?
Proficient or try to be at mastered
by taking a unit exam.
So that's what I do.
I teach and then I monitor this.
I'll even put this on the
big screen in my classroom.
I'll project this whole screen.
And I've trained them as a class.
I say, "Okay, class.
"Now here, you see names.
"Where you are in this
chart has nothing to do
"with how smart you are.
"This is all about just
where you're at right now.
"So let's all work together as a team
"and get up here to proficient.
"Let's work together as a team.
"And you kids who've become
proficient or mastered,
"You're now the designated peer tutors.
"Reach out to your table
members who are down here
"who are still struggling
them and help them out."
And I'll give big team
points or class points
and we can get everybody moved up.
Or I'll let these kids go to
recess early, or whatever.
So motivate kids like that.
And then also show the
growth charts, okay?
And just set a class culture
of we're here to support each other.
And everybody who works hard is rewarded,
even if you can't get up
to proficient or familiar.
If you work hard and reach out for help,
hey, you're moving on, you're
getting all the privileges
everybody else gets.
But I need to see it.
I need to see the effort and the belief
that you can learn by
putting in the effort
and sweat equity.
So now, back at the sixth grade progress.
As I teach, I'm monitoring this chart.
And I'll show the class.
I'll say, "Okay, class, the median.
"And we learn what median
means early on the year."
The middle kid in the class is right here.
Are you above or below?
And can you catch them
if you're down here?
And so I'll do that.
And I might also, I might say,
"Hey, so-and-so, this kid right here,
"did you know that your friend
is only 1% ahead of you?
"I bet if you work hard tonight,
"you can catch them up.
"In fact, I'll pay class
cash, or a raffle ticket,
"or some kind of class reward
if you can catch 'em up."
And then this kid's like,
"Oh no, I don't want that to happen.
"I'm not gonna let you beat me."
And so I have individual one,
V, one competitions as well,
using this data.
But it's all a class environment
of supporting and encouraging.
And you've gotta set that tone.
We are here to help each other.
And you praise the kids.
You grow a lot and move up.
And every kid can do it,
and we really believe in that.
Especially at the unit level,
they'll see bigger
growth on the unit level
when you click on unit.
For example, that unit that
I haven't even taught yet.
They'll see growth more rapid
because within a unit,
it's less materials.
So their growth happens more quickly.
Okay, so back to the presentation.
I just wanted you to
see that while I teach,
I then can use this data
to know who I need to go help,
who is struggling and
who needs assistance.
So back to the presentation.
So teach, support, but allow
them to work on their own.
And you saw the results of that.
Like half the class has
already learned a whole chunk
of that unit that I
haven't even taught yet.
So make it real.
Let them have some independence.
Next, motivate, encourage,
praise, reward, and celebrate.
What I do at the start of the year,
I really, really get
them excited about growth
and really believing that they can do it.
So I emphasize the mastery
of the lower grade level skills, K1, two.
These kids are like, "Psh, I can do this.
"I'm a sixth grader."
And they might secretly
struggle with some skills
like, "Mr. Vandenberg, I
forgot what a rhombus is.
"Can you tell me what that is?"
Or they might not have
ever truly had the chance
to learn or master what some
of these number sense skills are.
Did you know how they
start in common core,
they start learning
about distributive property
concepts pretty early.
So really have them go through
those foundational skills.
But they basically build
confidence and velocity
by focusing on lower grade
level review, remediation standards.
They're like, "Oh, I can do this.
"Look, now I know how to look at the hints
"to quickly learn how to do it.
"It's easy, it's first
grade, it's kindergarten,
"I can do this."
And so they learn how the system works
while it's still easy,
while secretly, they might come across
something they struggle with,
and they're like, "Okay, I need
to slow down and learn this.
"Get help from my teacher."
While they're doing this, their
self-pride will skyrocket.
As students build confidence
and self-agency through grit
and determination, utilizing
help resources as needed,
the videos, the hints, their peer buddies,
and you the teacher, and even parents
and older siblings at home.
Next part of this motivation piece.
Use those remedial courses.
And as they do the remedial courses,
have them begin with a course challenges.
Because they have supposedly
have already covered this before,
then supposedly, they
should be able to do it.
So say, "Hey, start at the end.
"Do the course challenge
"and the unit tests a few times."
And what that will do, it
will quickly bring them up
in their skill mastery a lot faster
than if they went skill by
skill through all the lessons.
It's a really rapid advancement.
And then what they did
not answer correctly,
than they can go and individually
work on those skills.
Have them do those course challenges.
It's kind of like a final exam
and end of year test,
and also the unit tests
a few times each.
But be aware, after so many times,
some of the questions do start to recycle.
So you don't want kids
doing that too many times.
And you'll have to use your judgment
where the questions start to recycle,
they're just memorizing answers,
copying answers down and reusing them.
So I only let them do them a few times,
maybe five times or so.
And then right around 10 times, I think,
questions start to recycle.
Somebody's who's an expert
will have to inform me on that.
So and then, if also at
the start of the year,
I focus on time on task.
Like first week of school,
I'll say, "Hey, guys, guess what?"
I can see how hard you're working.
So like, for example,
I go back up to this excellent feature
called activity overview.
This is set up for the
window of this semester.
Grades finished for first
semester on December 16th.
So ever since then, this
is their work since then.
So what I might do, I might
set this to just the last day
or two, and then I'll sort
by most minutes on task.
And I'll reward it.
I'll say, "Okay, kids.
"I will reward the top 10 kids
who work the most tonight.
"Now your required homework
is only 30 minutes tonight,
"but if you do more than that,
"if you're one of the top
10, boy, I'm gonna reward you
"big class cash or big team points,
"or some privilege or some
reward or something like that."
So that they get hooked on the successes
of burning through quickly
those early grade level skills
and really mastering them.
Next, after awhile, after
a few weeks of that,
I phase out of focusing
on minutes on task.
'Cause you can fake the minutes on task
by just leaving the screen open.
The smart kids start to figure that out.
Then I started focusing
instead on skills leveled up.
And I'll say, "Okay, the top 10 kids
"who level up the most
skills tonight for homework,
"I'm gonna give them big rewards.
"So make sure you're focusing
on skills leveled up."
So that's one way I
really motivate the kids.
I met set them individually rewards,
or team rewards or class
rewards for all that.
So okay, back to presentation.
So that's what this is all about.
And so as you teach them
to rely on those videos,
hints, elbow buddies and you.
Next, praise and reward individual, team,
and whole class effort and progress.
Educational research has shown
that kids need three levels of motivation.
Usually your higher achieving kids,
what works with them the best
is individual motivation,
individual rewards.
Your average achieving kids
need more like small group rewards,
like a team or a table group,
or maybe a class versus
a class, if you're high
school, junior high teacher,
period versus period.
And then, the lower kids,
they need more whole class
where they can blend in and
work as a whole giant team
because they know they
can still chip in and not
be singled out.
And they might be embarrassed
if their growth is shown.
But boy, if they chip in and
help the whole class achieve,
then they will definitely
help make a big difference.
And their growth will still go up
without any individual focus on them.
So that's basically, that
was life-changing for me
when I learned that decades
ago about motivating kids
on those three levels,
individual, team, and whole class.
So reward and praise accordingly.
Next, here's some ideas to do all that.
Khan Academy has some free certificates
you can download.
Jeremy can give you the link for that.
Class cash, that's what
I use, or raffle tickets,
or homework heroes, or team
points, or classwide challenges,
or like I was saying earlier,
one V. one skill mastery challenges.
Pit friends against friends.
Who can, you know, I bet you
can catch up to your buddy
this week or tonight
or in this class period
if you work hard.
Or who can level up the most skills today,
and just today only?
And I like to show unit and
skill progress charts live,
all with the culture of we are all here
to support each other,
and everybody who works hard,
I don't care how low your progress is.
As long you work hard, you'll
be praised and rewarded.
Okay, another way to motivate.
Use grades.
Khan Academy should be used for grades.
In fact, I trust Khan Academy better
than most assessments by far,
based on mastery.
And for me, a grade is never locked in.
A grade can go up if they keep leveling
up their mastery for a course.
Or a grade can go down until report cards.
Once report cards happen
their grade is locked in,
especially semester report cards.
Grades are locked in.
But by the end of the year,
they can keep working.
Right now as we're remote learning,
even though work is not required
because of the remote
learning equity concerns,
the kids can still
optionally keep working.
And they are, they're
leveling up their skills.
I've had kids who've worked
hours and hours leveling skills
while they're at home
on their Chromebooks,
working on their skills.
Here's a pro tip, that I suggest
you do what works best for you,
but I highly recommend that you use
Khan Academy assignments for grades.
The assignments, there's
a really fantastic feature
called Assignments where you
can assign specific skills to kids.
And they're super powerful
for seeing how the kids are doing.
And because it'll tell
you how the whole class
did on every single question.
It's super powerful, but
I highly recommend you use
that for grades sparingly,
unless you're one of those teachers
who has all the time in the world
to enter assignment grades,
individual assignment
grades into your grade book,
and keep them updating regularly.
So let's say they got a 67%
on one of the assignments you give 'em,
is that locked in forever?
What about growth mindset
and mastery learning?
What if they learn that
skill later in the year,
and they read through the assignment,
and they get 100% on it?
You gonna go back and change it?
Well, I don't have time for all that.
So I do use the Assignments
feature to signal
to kids what I want them to work on.
And also, if I just wanna
get a pulse on how well
they're learning as a class,
and what specific kinds
of questions I need to reteach.
But I don't use assignments
for grades barely ever.
Instead, let me show
you my assignment book.
Hopefully my grade book did not,
oh, good, okay.
All right, so this is my grade book.
I slid it over so you cannot
see the names of the kids.
But this is my grades.
Here's early math.
And you can see at the
bottom of that black box.
It says, "This assignment
is weighted .333."
So 1/3 of the value of my
regular sixth grade assignment.
Early third grade, that's half the value
'cause three is half of six.
Sixth grade and arithmetic,
those are full value.
And notice that's out of 100 points.
I just go in every two or three weeks,
enter their Khan Academy progress scores,
on the progress tab that you already saw
and I just update this.
And I say, okay, based
on the progress chart.
So let's say we're talking,
let's see here.
Let's say, back to this.
Some of you have already
seen this progress chart.
This is the pacing guide that I use.
Let's say it's week
five of the school year.
Let's say you assigned
kindergarten, first, second, third,
fourth, fifth, all those to your kids.
They should 100% in kindergarten
mastered, 100% in first
100% of second, 63% of third,
31% of fourth and 16% of fifth and sixth.
And arithmetic should be mastered by now,
by the week that ends on September 13th.
So that's what I make it in my grade book.
I make the sixth grade
course out of 16 points.
And if they're passed that grade,
they have over 100% on that.
If they're less than 16%,
than it'll mark it accordingly.
And so I keep typing that in
and keep updating that.
And as the weeks go on, I
change what it's out of.
And eventually, this is my pacing guide.
Some of you've already seen this.
And it'll be linked,
Jeremy will make sure
it's linked somewhere
after this presentation.
By Spring Break, everything is done.
Everything should be 100%.
And that's where we are.
We're at Spring Break.
So back to the grade book.
Here it is.
So by now, everything should be at 100%.
And just a couple hours ago,
I went in and I updated grades
based on what kids have been
doing on remote learning.
And this is how they're doing,
how much they've mastered
of the whole grade level.
And I just keep updating that
every two or three weeks.
So I'm only changing these grades
two or three times, maybe
twice a month at most.
This is a math fact, so I
use a separate third party
math facts program, add,
subtract, multiple, divide,
fraction, decimal, percent
conversions, things like that.
And I also grade effort.
And that's in a slideshow in a second,
but I may as well talk about it right now.
I give an effort grade
and it's based on how
hard the class is working.
I basically take the top 10 kids.
And basically, the tenth kid in the class
has worked this semester,
since December 16th,
3,000 minutes on tasks.
So I make it out at 300
and then move the decimal place over.
So all these kids with 300 points,
they have an effort grade of
basically 300 out 300, 100%.
Anybody with less than that
'cause they're not going
home and doing their homework
or not working in class like they should,
it's less than 300.
But this is just a little grade to buffer
because look, it says this assignment,
the bottom of that black box,
"This assignment is
weighted at .01 it's value."
So it's really a 30-point assignment.
But it's a nice little buffer
to reward those kids who are working hard.
And the kids like this
one who are really smart.
Look at this, great scores.
Mastering most of the
material fantastically.
But that student's not trying so hard.
They really should be trying hard,
so it kind of lowers their
grade a little bit for effort.
So that's still part of the grade.
Okay, so back to the presentation.
So that's how I do grades.
But I do recommend using
the assignments sparingly.
But you do what works for you.
But make sure you follow
the mastery learning model
if you wanna be able to do all this.
Next, let effort count.
We just talked about that.
Okay, but watch out for grade inflation.
I have taught high school and junior high.
I have tutored dozens
and dozens of high school
and junior high and college students.
And I know how some secondary
teachers inflate grades
by knowing their kids
will fail the state test.
But boy, if they work
hard on their homework,
and then are nice in class
and try hard in class,
boy, I'll give 'em an A.
'Cause they do their homework,
even though all their homework is wrong.
Well, I don't give grades like that.
I'll give a little bit of an effort grade
that'll raise 'em up a
little bit for their effort
which Khan Academy measures
for you beautifully and easily.
But make sure it's balanced
so that the kids who work hard,
but don't learn the material,
they're not just getting an A.
An A should mean they're
mastering the material,
at least proficient or better.
So you balance it out so it's just right.
So the real learning is really happening.
Letter G, use non-Khan assessment scores
to verify learning and to
disincentivize cheating.
What do I mean by that?
So back to the grade book.
Over here, you'll see some other grades.
This is common formative assessments
that my grade level does.
Some of you know about PLCs,
professional learning communities.
We have common formative assessments.
And we've been doing practice state test,
the Interim Assessment Block Test
they call them in California.
These are like real
practice state unit tests.
And I use those, but I balance them out
so that it doesn't not skew the scores.
So this way, if the kid is
proving that they're learning
on third party assessments,
they're still gonna do great on the tests.
Make sure these other
assessments, quizzes, and tests
are rigorous, and truly
match the state standards
in their rigorousness.
But also, you give enough weight and value
to mastering skills on Khan Academy
that they're still passing your class
with a great grade.
But make sure their learning is real.
This is what I mean
by avoid cheating,
disincentivize cheating.
Have you ever had kids cheat?
(laughing)
Has that ever happened?
I know with any sort of teaching,
cheating can happen.
Well, on Khan Academy,
kids can open up a new tab
and go to Google Calculator
and type in the problem
on a calculator, or use their calculator
they have in their desk and do the work
without doing it for real.
Now Khan Academy sometimes
does give a calculator
and they should use that,
just like a state test would do that too,
at least in California.
But if they're doing superb
on their Khan Academy mastery,
but they fail my third party,
non-Khan Academy assessments,
I become highly suspicious of
their learning over on Khan.
And if a kid fails a quiz or test
and they claim they're Khan data shows
that they were mastering it,
I say, "Okay, tell you what,
"do that unit test on Khan.
"And I'm watching you,
and I'm gonna make sure
"that you're not using a calculator.
"Go ahead, get started."
And they might say, "Oh, well you know,
"I forgot how to do it."
Well then you never
learned it to begin with
because Khan mastery is all
about long-term learning.
That's the way it's designed.
So you discover the cheaters
real quick that way.
Another form of cheating
is your peer tutor buddies.
I really have to train the class,
make sure that peer tutors,
when they're helping their friends,
makes sure that the hints are showing
because when you click, "Hints open",
Khan Academy will not give credit
for that question being answered.
So make sure the hints are showing.
And I allow their friends
to help all they want
'cause the hints are showing.
That means they won't get
credit for answering right,
so they can discuss it with them
and talk them through the
problems step-by-step,
no big deal.
But if the hints are not showing,
then they're cheating
because they're gonna get how
to do it, and get the answer
and Khan'll think they knew
how to do it on their own.
So make sure that's going on.
Okay, back to slide show.
Okay, non-Khan assessments, letter H.
Keep intrinsic and extrinsic
motivation balanced,
emphasizing intrinsic motivation.
That self-pride and
self-worth is just amazing.
It totally sky rockets.
But remember,
most teachers don't teach for free,
so some extrinsic reward is okay.
Hey, I still need a paycheck
to take care of my family,
even though I would teach
for free if I could.
But I still need a paycheck.
Well, our kids, some of them, it's okay
to get class cash or homework passes
or special rewards or privileges,
or whatever extrinsic
rewards you wanna give
with the balance of the major
focus is intrinsic reward,
believing that they can do it.
Moving on, number 10, release control.
Give your kids independence.
Once you've taught several
skills or whatever skill
you just taught, let 'em go and allow
for personalized, variable pace
while setting high expectations
toward proficiency and mastery.
And trust that the learning is real.
I mean, you gotta make
sure they're not cheating.
But make sure that they're
really doing it on their own,
at their own pace while
you're supporting them,
and they're friends are supporting them.
Trust it, it works.
It really is real.
Number 11, this is
something a lot of teachers
don't think about until it happens.
You need to use your own
professional judgment
regarding your special ed kids,
also the kids that transfer to your class
or school late in the year,
and hard-working, low-ability kids
that just struggle with math.
In my class, the policy
is all hard-working kids
get a C minus or higher.
And I make sure I follow
whatever laws are in place
with students' IEPs,
or required for me to do
with their special ed needs.
And low-ability kids, hey,
I promise all parents,
'cause some parents are
like, "Well, you know,
"I had never had my kid
actually have to earn
"their A before.
"What if they work hard and get a D
"'cause they're low at math?"
I say, "Hey, your kid works hard,
"I promise them a C minus or better."
And that usually, parents are like,
the way they respond is usually, "Finally,
"for the first time in my child's life,
"and even my own life,
"as a parent when I was
young, this is the first time
"his teacher's gonna grade my kid
"based on them actually learning,
"not just 'cause they're
cute and smile and act nice."
So they love that.
Number 12, don't forget, come April, May,
you still gotta review
for the big state test,
or whatever you gotta do in your state.
And now this year a lot of states,
and I know federally because
of the whole coronavirus thing,
state tests in California
and I think across the
nation have been canceled
or postponed or something like that.
But for next year, when
we get back to normal,
you still gotta review
'cause some of their skill mastery
was months ago, months ago.
So review with unit tests on Khan Academy,
the course challenges.
Make the kids retake those.
And they're gonna say,
but I forgot how to do it.
Well, that's good.
You'll get to learn
what you need to review.
And non-Khan assessments, use all those.
Number 13, be aware with
any digital platform,
cheating is possible.
We've already talked about that.
Number 14, last point.
Remind them constantly,
they are changing their lives forever.
This is real, this is
gonna change their lives
as it has for my students
the last three years.
And I know for a fact, based
on the practice state tests
that my kids were taking,
that this would've been the fourth year,
had we gotten to take the real state test,
that my kids would've just blown
their previous growth out of the water
with huge growth.
I predicted my kids probably would've
grown about 100 points this year
if we had a state test,
on average in growth.
So here's some resources.
Jeremy, you're gonna
take it over from here.
So it's all you.
- First of all, a huge
shout out back to you, Tim
'cause this is amazing.
Like I think the very
first webinar you did
was kind of an appetizer, an
hors d'oeuvre, if you will.
This is absolutely the main course.
So I think both they're feeling,
both really satiated, but also
hungry for the next thing.
And so I do have a couple of
burning questions for you.
- Don't forget you guys,
you'll get a recording.
And go back and rewind
and rewatch and pause,
and email Jeremy.
Bug him with your questions.
(laughing)
- Yeah, so Tim, the
generous saint that he is,
offered his own email
address in the last webinar
and lived to regret that.
So please funnel all
questions to me going forward.
- I do not regret that.
I do not regret that.
I was very happy to do
that, but I'm now wiser.
So go ahead, Jeremy (chuckles).
- Cool, so I wanna address
the elephant in the room.
And it's coming in.
Keith, as well as a
couple of other educators.
Keith says, "This amazing and I would love
"to do this at the start
of the school year,
"but given these very
unusual circumstances
"we find ourselves in with 10 weeks left
"to remote learning, what would you do
"if someone was starting
totally brand new with this
"right now at this time?"
- Okay, so if I was a teacher.
We're all doing remote
learning, something like that,
keep up with your normal assignments.
Don't change things right now.
You're gonna have major
kickback from parents
and probably administrators who hear
from those angry parents.
Don't change your class
routines right now.
But what I would do, I would allow
an extra credit opportunity
to buffer grades, especially
for those struggling kids.
Make sure that it's balanced in a way
that doesn't warp their grades.
They still focus on your
current grade level assignments.
But I would go ahead and
assign for extra credit
the early math, the
arithmetic, and for secondary,
the pre-algebra courses.
And tell the kids, "Hey,
this is extra credit.
"And I'll give double extra credit
"to the two or three
kids who master the most
"or grow the most on these."
Or whatever, I don't know.
You use your own teacher magic.
You know your kids the best.
But I would still assign this
as an extra credit assignment,
as an easy review.
Tell them, hey, this is easy.
But don't forget to start
with the course challenges
'cause they'll quickly level up,
and they'll quickly show
that, "Wow, I can do this.
"Oh, wait, I never learned
this kindergarten skill.
"I don't what this is."
'Cause this happened
every year with my kids.
There's so much they learn,
but they did not learn in kindergarten,
first, second, third grade.
But by going back, you
should see the little looks
on their faces, like, "Wow.
"I never realized that we
were supposed to learn this,
"and now I can't do this little skill
"that's for little kids."
So I would do that,
assign it as an extra
credit optional assignment,
unless you're allowed to make it required.
Use your own judgment.
That's what I would do and let it enhance
and supplement grades.
Otherwise, they'll be like,
"Well, you know, why am I doing this?"
Well, it'll change your
life is what it'll do.
And tell them this is great summer work.
Tell the parents, work
on this over the summer.
And they can keep you posted.
As teachers, you can keep
your Khan Academy classes
and watch their growth and
encourage them over the summer
if you have district emails with them,
and you can still confer
with them through district channels.
So all right, that's my advice for that.
- Okay, amazing.
So now let's fast forward
a little bit to September.
Let's assume that we get back to normalcy
at some point, fingers crossed.
Even if you wanted to do this
under perfect circumstances,
the number one question we're getting,
this is really nicely put by Kelly,
where do you get the time?
Kelly says, "We have a four-day week,
"so the semester has about 65 to 70 days.
"If were to take away
testing, FFA, sports,
"so maybe 50 to 60 days,
"40 to 50 standards per
grade, et cetera, et cetera.
"How do you make time for this
in this crazy, hectic world
"that educators inhabit?"
- Okay, like I said at the beginning.
The first disclaimer,
you need to make this fit your situation,
your parameters, your
boundaries and guidelines.
So if you notice that on-task data.
My kids have averaged since December 16th,
the start of grading
for the second semester
'cause I had to have grades
done on December 16th
for the first semester.
My average, hard-working
student averaged about an hour
a day of Khan activity.
Do your kids have time for an hour a day?
That counts class time and homework time.
I bet you can make that happen,
especially if you motivate
kids to go above and beyond
and especially when your
students begin to realize
that you are gonna grade based on mastery,
not based on did they try hard
but fail their quiz?
You know, you don't just give an A
'cause they tried hard, but
they can't actually do the work.
When you start showing an expectation
of grading based on mastery,
your 30 kids are used to
getting all As and Bs,
even for the high class,
especially for the high classes
that come to you at the secondary level.
They'll start to realize,
wait, wait, wait.
You mean I have to actually learn this?
Not just turn in a homework page
with all the wrong answers.
You know, they're used to that.
What they need to start getting used to is
they have to actually
prove that they learned it.
And kids love the fact
that you can actually track their growth.
And so they start working
harder and they start working
above and beyond 30 minutes
of homework a night.
And at the secondary level, most teachers
are comfortable, safe,
and legally protected
to assign an hour of homework a night.
I bet they can get that done.
Now the balance, as I've been answering
a lot of the teachers' questions,
the balance of practice, skill practice
that I've had is about half of their time,
50% of their time on Khan
spent on sixth grade work,
and other half of their time spent
on K through five review material,
or the early math class
and the arithmetic class.
That's what I do.
This class I have this year
is even 20 points lower than last year
as they came to me.
And so I learned after the first semester,
"Hey, I'm gonna adjust.
"I'm gonna take away the
forth grade and fifth grade
"and just make them do early math,
"third grade, and arithmetic."
So also be flexible.
But there is time if you start
making them prove their learning,
as opposed to making math about busy work
and memorizing algorithms.
So that's my thoughts on that.
They can do it.
And even you start making them do it
in the time that you do have,
they will still learn far better
than under the old, time-driven model.
Focus on mastery, not get
done what you can in two weeks
and that's it.
- Great, and Tim, do you have
time for one last question?
- Oh, I have all the
time you want, Jeremy.
We'll make this as long as you want.
- Well, I gotta get
you back to your family
'cause they're gonna wonder
if you've been abducted
being the one teacher left at your school.
But let me ask you
this, one, last question
'cause I think you've actually hit
on a lot of the other questions
that were asked about what
do with Khan for homework?
What do you do in terms of
assigning course mastery goals?
I think the really powerful
thing about this session
is now, as an educator myself,
I can actually visualize
what it looks like.
I think the one, missing piece
that Hmong is asking about
is what are you doing while your students
are working on Khan?
Can you sort of help us visualize
how that looks?
- Okay, so if you watched
the video earlier in the
slide deck about what it looks
like in my classroom,
you know, you teach.
They take notes.
You practice it as a class.
And then while they're working on Khan,
I'm circulating among the students
on tracking the growth data
on that skill or that particular skill
or that unit and seeing who's moving up
and who needs help,
touching base with each of those kids
that are struggling and making sure
they're getting the help they need
and moving along.
I'm not just sitting at my
desk, reading the Sports page.
You know, I'm not at espn.com.
I'm circulating around and
helping the kids as needed,
encouraging peer buddies to
reach out to their friends.
"Hey, there's somebody at your table
"that need help.
"Can you help them out?"
That kind of stuff.
So I don't have one math class.
I have 30 math classes,
and 30 peer tutors.
Sometimes I'll have my lowest
kids master skills first,
and they become the peer tutor master
to help the kids that might
be smarter, supposedly,
but haven't learned it yet.
So you're actively engaged.
You're not babysitting.
- Cool, I love it.
Well, I think you've inspired us,
especially in this relatively dark time,
to aim for something
even brighter and higher
in our own educational lives.
I know there are a lot
questions left out there.
And I promise to protect Tim's sanity
and his inbox.
So please shoot me questions
with anything that's on your mind.
I'm JeremySchifeling@khanacademy.org.
And on behalf of Khan
Academy and behalf of Tim,
I wanna thank you for investing in this.
I know our time is very scarce right now.
We have a lot on our shoulders,
but the fact that you showed up,
the fact that you sort
of learned from what Tim
has done and sort of taught
himself the hard way.
I think this says a lot.
And Tim, thank you so much
for making us all wiser
with sharing your expertise
and paying it forward.
So thank you all again.
- Jeremy, if I can just
say one last thing.
Teachers, trust your
professional judgment.
Do what works for you and your kids.
There's no one right way.
And you learn by doing.
So you just gotta dive in and go for it.
- Well, on that note, hope
everyone has a wonderful evening
and a great start to the weekend.
Wishing you all tremendous success.
- Good night, everybody.
- Cheers.